- [Instructor] Borderlands
Food Bank, an organization
in Nogales, Arizona rescue
millions of pounds of
slightly imperfect
imported food every year.
And then they underline the verb rescue,
and we see all of the choices
here are have rescued,
are rescuing, rescues, so they're all
different forms of the verb rescue.
So, let's just think about it.
Let's first of all, what
is doing the rescuing?
So, we see the thing
that's doing the rescuing
is Borderlands Food Bank.
Borderlands Food Bank,
which is an organization
in Nogales, Arizona.
Now, is Borderlands Food Bank
one thing or many things?
Is it singular or is it plural?
Well, we're only talking
about one organization.
We're only talking about one food bank,
and so this right over here is singular.
This is singular.
It's not Borderlands Food Banks.
Now, if you're not careful
when you see this S here,
your brain might say, oh, I'm
dealing with something plural.
But it's Borderlands Food Bank,
not Borderlands Food Banks.
So, we have a singular subject here,
and now what about the verb?
Is this the verb that we would
use for a singular subject?
Would you say, would you say,
let's say, he, would you say he rescue?
He rescue, or would you say he rescues?
Let me make those he
rescues, he rescues food,
he rescue food, or would
you write he rescues food?
Rescues food.
Well, if you have a singular subject,
the singular form of the
verb rescue is rescues.
So, since we have a singular subject here,
we want to say Borderlands Food Bank,
an organization in Nogales,
Arizona rescues millions of
pounds of slightly imperfect
imported food every year.
Rescue, this right over here,
that is the plural form of the verb.
So, you would say they rescue.
They rescue food.
If you have a plural subject,
if you have a plural subject,
then you would go with rescue.
So, this is the plural form,
but you have a singular
subject, so you don't want that.
You want the singular form of the verb.
Singular form of the verb.
You want rescues, so you
want rescues right over here.
So, we already saw why we
definitely wanted to change it
because it was the plural form.
And actually, all of these
are also plural forms,
but just in different tenses.
If you say have, have rescued,
have, you don't say he
have done something.
You would say he has done something.
You would say they have done something.
So, this is still a plural form,
and once again, you wouldn't
say he are rescuing,
you would say they are rescuing,
so this also is a plural form.
So, the first three choices
are all the plural form
even though they're different tenses.
Both plural form, even though
that the subject is singular.
This right over here
has the appropriate verb
for a singular subject.